hello there I'm Gavin down where the
slow mo guys and we're here in the
Nevada desert you know as you do you
just stand in the desert nothing here so
if they going on right place to fire
guns great place to fire guns guns a
slow mo always great big thanks to EA
for sponsoring this video we're here to
promote battlefield one dan what do you
like about the First World War the Great
War it's the amount of tech that was
made as a kid I never understood how
they managed to do the thing where they
fired machine guns through the
propellers of planes I just didn't
understand it the odd sync gear yeah and
now I'm a grown-up and I've saw the
Internet's been invented to look it up
and I had something called sink gear
like you said where the bullets manage
to just go in between the propellers and
so they could fly the plane and shoot
where they're looking at as opposed to
trying to control a gun and the plane at
the same time yeah imagine is really
hard
well it's very difficult to find a world
war 1 plane that still shoots live ammo
through its own propeller but thankfully
we've been up to recreate exactly that
with this device and we're gonna film it
and extremely high speeds yeah I'll whip
this up last night I can't wait to get
on it you made this today hammer
screwdriver a Phillips head yeah yeah
and a number 2 monkey wrench number 3
actually number 3 yeah all right well
let's take a look at this thing yeah I
mean that's a funny sight I think that's
you short for this ting well they taller
Mobil 1 or something I don't think there
are being the most laughable thing in
the world but Fred Flintstone through
the Bob know these things I've done yeah
what gun is this then also this is a
Vickers machine gun from World War one
authentic stuff I mean in actual fact we
can get hold of all those so we turned
an m60 upside down and stuck one of
these bad boys on it and the heat sink
to make it look cool which it does I
like the sound of an m60 well I've only
said I've only shot them in video games
but it's always like meeting
that's a majestic looking for I love how
it's so close to the propeller bullets
going past it like here like how last
minute can we fire the bullets Lee
eeks right bar man and it's amazing when
we're on the the 25 11 120,000 FPS it
pretty much just pauses the propeller
yeah this is moving fast yeah so the
normal ice is moving rapidly but the
bullet is just moving on an order of
magnitude that's just way faster so this
is hovering in the air and that's like
yeah look we could have just stopped
this place yeah buying sweet shot done
you know although well I'm pretty sure
90% of the audience watching this yeah I
thinking I know what you're thinking
what happens if it hits right yeah yeah
so we could desync we could turn off the
sink here yeah so that instead of just
shooting at the right time we just
unload with the machine gun completely
and hopefully by chance we'll get it
hitting through the propeller just
thrashing it just sort of like go for it
see what happens
the Alea imagine imagine landing like a
successful mission and you're just like
oh man
you just Park up like yeah another yeah
right Lister do you think is leasing the
thinking yeah
so we took off the sink here and looks
like we got four hits
yeah I'm judging by the high-speed one
went straight through the hole it was
already made by a previous one so it's
one two three
and then little nick there miss four fry
an egg yeah not well we learned that if
you keep your propeller around 200 rpm
it can survive a couple of bullets
through it yeah I mean normally when
you're flying one of these things they
go round at 1,200 rpm well we couldn't
which means they turn it down a little
well if we have that going at that speed
on the ground we just start generated
juddering along the floor and take it
off hard to focus on a moving plane yeah
well hopefully you enjoyed that video I
certainly did I found it very
interesting
feel free to follow us on Twitter buy a
shirt we've got a second channel and
most importantly today make sure you
check out battlefield one I actually pre
downloaded it on a on that on my PC over
there so I have to so we can go and play
over there yeah in the desert yeah yeah